salut tout le monde
j'ai dix minutes
ça fait bizarre d'être là je suis pas à
l'aise du tout c'est un truc un peu
particulier je peu habitué à parler
devant un drapeau bleu-blanc-rouge
pas habitués à voir un pupitre aussi
jolie que ça
voilà bon alors du coup je suis philippe
poutou candidat pour le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste
pas seulement candidat je suis un peu
collègues aussi ce que je suis élu
conseiller municipal de bordeaux et je
suis élu conseil métropolitain de
bordeaux métropole donc voilà on est un
peu collègues
alors je suis censé dire un peu ce qu'on
pense de tout ça des collectivités
territoriales de des municipalités du
travail
je ne sais pas par quoi commencer il ya
une question démocratique qui nous vient
de suite à l'idée on est dans un monde à
notre avis très peu démocratique et
malheureusement y compris les structures
territoriales ou les structures
démocratiques locales le sont aussi peu
et donc c'est le problème auquel on est
confronté mois déjà en tant que
conseiller municipal c'est ce que j'ai
pu voir c'est cette sorte de déconnexion
qui peut y avoir entre un pouvoir qui
est déjà établir c'est vrai qu'entre les
grandes villes les grandes communes et
les petites communes c'est pas non plus
du tout la même chose nous on l'a vu en
rencontrant les maires à la course aux
parrainages on a vu que c'était pas le
même monde que ce n'était pas le même
travail et envoyer les écarts assez
important de deux préoccupations de
de qualité du fin du travail fin donc on
a vu tout ça et c'est vrai que c'est un
vrai problème cette sorte d'inégalité du
territoire où il ya des grosses
métropoles des grosses villes qui
concentrent l'activité le pouvoir et les
richesses et puis d'un autre côté la
grosse galère pour les pour les petites
communes avec des petites équipes peu de
moyens souvent bien aller bien tenus à
l'écart et puis souvent aussi on a vu un
dans les avis ne compte pas en fait
[Musique]